d'être venu et d'avoir répondu à mon
invitation et de s'être rendu à moscou
on sait que son emploi du temps il
serait chargé en ce moment et monsieur
le président a aussi un certain nombre
de rencontres importantes au niveau
intérieur il y aura un référendum sur la
nouvelle constitution du pays très
prochainement et nous souhaitons à nos
amis biélorusse que ce référendum se
déroule de façon correcte les
discussions d'aujourd'hui se sont
déroulées dans une atmosphère tout à
fait tranquille de confiance et de
respect
conformément à la tradition
et comme les deux parties loin dit à
plusieurs reprises nous sommes des pays
voisins nous avons instruit un
partenariat stratégique
nous avons une histoire commune des
valeurs communes des liens de famille
une coopération multilatérale qui se
fait sur les bases du respect mutuel et
du respect des intérêts mutuels bien
entendu nous accordons une grande
attention à l'extension des relations
commerciales
et malgré les difficultés liées à la
pandémie le volume des échanges ne cesse
d'augmenter
et l'année dernière
ce volume a augmenté de d'un tiers
ce qui représente 38 milliards de
dollars
à peu près la moitié de la production
biélorusse est exportée en russie est de
notre côté nous sommes un des leaders en
matière d'investissement dans le secteur
de l'industrie réel en biélorussie
et ne représentant plus de la moitié des
investissements étrangers en biélorussie
et nous espérons pouvoir créer des
conditions plus favorables encore pour
les milieux d'affaires pour les
entreprises et en soutenant des
initiatives
entrepreneuriat le thème central de nos
discussions portaient sur le
développement des processus
d'intégration et de construction de nos
deux états nous avons proposé des
décisions stratégiques qui vont être
soumises
au conseil qui en a déjà examiné en
novembre dernier donc le conseil
d'intégration de nos deux pays et donc
il ya 7 notamment ce traité d'union de
nos deux états et il y aller
38 programmes conjoints qui ont déjà été
déterminé l'année dernière des deux
côtés
nous comprenons bien que les ministères
et services concernés mène un travail
tout à fait productif sur l'ensemble de
ses programmes et notamment le groupe de
travail de coopération à montrer donc
des résultats tout à fait satisfaisants
il y avait une réunion donc mi décembre
dernier en matière de coopération
politique aussi entre nos deux
gouvernements il ya aussi un fort volume
de coopération qui a été multiplié par
20 l'année dernière par huit par dont
l'année dernière avec monsieur le
président loukachenko nous sommes en
constamment en contact
et notamment sur les processus de
d'intégration de d'édification de l'état
ces derniers temps au début un certain
nombre de progrès notamment en matière
de transports avec le transit de
beaucoup de produits de biélorussie qui
passe par la russie nous allons et
inversement et nous allons
augmenter ce volume d'échangés en
matière financière aussi des mesures
sont prises en commun pour pouvoir
contourner les les sanctions légitimes
qui ont été imposées tombe contre nos
deux pays et qui ont forcément un impact
sur nos économies
nous travaillons aussi de façon active
en matière d'amélioration des systèmes
de de paiement entre les deux pays ont
système de paiement des impôts et des
changes aussi en matière énergétique jeu
celui que tous nos efforts de
satisfaction de l'emploi du temps est de
l'ordre du jour de la cobas entre nos
deux pays se manifestent par une
amélioration du niveau de vie de nos
habitants et d'une croissance économique
nos projets d'intégration ont d ampleur
différente ça veut dire que
l'état unifiée de nos deux pays fait que
le volume de nos échanges en produits en
services et en emplois ce devient de
plus en plus stable de plus en plus
fiables aussi et à la terre nantes au
terme de nos discussions aujourd'hui
nous allons encore prendre des mesures
pour renforcer cette tendance tout à
fait positive
et nous cherchons à prendre aussi toutes
les mesures nécessaires de façon
collective pour assurer notre sécurité
pour protéger notre sécurité et cela
passe par la coopération militaire entre
nos deux pays et dans ce contexte nous
avons particulièrement apprécié les
exercices militaires
résolution 2022 qui on est et qui vient
d'être menée
et je dois constater que ces exercices
militaires ou un caractère résolument
défensif et ne menace personne
nous avons proclamé les objectifs
principaux de ces manoeuvres et aux
cours
de ces exercices comme j'en ai informé
le président loukachenko qui assistent à
citer assisté à certains exercices
nous avons souligné que les pays
étrangers peuvent
assister à ces
manoeuvres et voir de leurs propres yeux
comment cela se passe nous développons
aussi le thème
de notre défense collective vis-à-vis
des de l'otan et des états unis nous
considérons comme tout à fait naturel
que la question qui nous préoccupe en
matière de sécurité préoccupe aussi nos
collègues de biélorussie
la promotion des revendications de la
russie se résume encore je le répète le
la non extension de l'otan vers l'est
cela le non déploiement d'armes
offensives à proximité des frontières
russes et le retour au statu quo de 1997
et en s'appuyant sur l'acte fondateur
des relations russie otan aujourd'hui
malheureusement nous constatons que nos
partenaires occidentaux ne sont
malheureusement pas prêt à discuter
normalement donc il ya un certain nombre
d'idées qui ont été émises en matière de
sécurité notamment sur les armes à
portée intermédiaire et la russie n'est
pas contre l'idée de discuter sur ces
questions là à condition que toutes les
questions soient
discutées de manière globale et non pas
séparées les unes des autres
car la sécurité de la russie est la
priorité avec monsieur locaux chaîne que
nous avons abordé aussi la question du
conflit interne à le cren le processus
de règlement
tarder a toujours malgré nos efforts et
les contacts que nous avons avec les
pays membres du format normandie les
consultations que nous avons mené pour
l'instant les consultations que nous
avons malheureusement les autorités de
kiev se refuse à avoir des intérêts
directs avec
lougansk de donetsk et se refuse à
apporter des changements dans le dans le
la constitution du pays
et les droits de l'homme sont
massivement enfreint en ukraine il ya
des discriminations à l'égard de la
population russophone et avec le
président biélorusse nous avons constaté
que
l'établissement de cette paix civile et
la levée de la pression
c'est justement ce qui est dans les
accords de minsk il faut donc que tous
les représentants
et de kiev et de lougansk et de donetsk
puisse se mettre autour d'une table et
discuter ensemble et plus tôt ce sera
mieux ce sera malheureusement là
maintenant nous à nous apprenons que la
situation ne cesse de s'aggraver sur
place encore une fois pour conclure je
voudrais exprimer ma reconnaissance à
monsieur le président loukachenko pour
le travail accompli aujourd'hui je suis
convaincu que les négociations
d'aujourd'hui permettront de renforcer
le travail d'intégration entre nos deux
pays et demandent eux participeront
à
une rencontre
dans le cadre des exercices militaires
conjoints je vous remercie chers amis
notre réunion d'aujourd'hui avec
monsieur poutine se déroule sur le fond
d'une augmentation sans précédent à des
tensions militaires dans le monde dont
le président via de paris vient de
parler compte tenu du caractère grave de
la situation nous avons accordé une
importance particulière à cette question
à ses sujets en discutant de nos
possibles des efforts conjoints en tant
que réponse aux actions agressives des
partenaires occidentaux je souligne
personne ne veut de guerre personne ne
veut même une simple aggravation des
conflits nous n'en avons pas besoin ni
les russes ni les biélorusses
vous qui êtes au courant à des sujets
vous voyez que ça ne dépend plus de nous
voisins notamment de l'ukraine de qui ça
dépend
cette augmentation des tensions au sur
nos frontières vous le connaissez
évidemment très bien pour la première
fois depuis des décennies nous sommes au
bord d'un conflit malheureusement
susceptibles de entraîner l'ensemble du
continent
dans cette situation nous voyons qu'il y
a le manque de responsabilité et le
manque d'esprit et le manque
d'intelligence dans certain nombre d
hommes politiques occidentaux on ne peut
pas voir d'eau logique on peut pas
trouvé d'explication le compare aux
comportements des dirigeants dans nombre
de pays et alors volonté d'être
justement d'aller jusqu'au bout
monsieur poutine a parlé de cette
aggravation de la situation dans le dos
basse malheureusement c'est ça les gens
sont prêts déjà à courir et peut-être y
sont déjà en train de le faire comme on
le sait ceci n'est pas normal j'ai
l'impression que
c'est les personnes des hommes
politiques
de ce monde libre ont cette pathologie
ils sont
sont dangereux pour ceux qui les
entourent et pour leur propre peuple
dans quelques jours seulement se
terminera elles se termineront les
exercices conjoints avec la russie c'est
youzhny les chimistes 2022 demain nous
aurons ensemble en événements avec
monsieur poutine sur le territoire de la
fédération de russie
d'eau
les médias seront informés en ce qui
concerne les exercices qui sont en train
de se terminer
j'ai déjà expliqué les sens et le
président vient d'en parler dans la
condition où on voit le danger militaire
qui s'accroît sur nos frontières on voit
que l'ukraine reçoit de plus en plus des
armes et dans ces conditions la russie
la biélorussie doivent chercher des
moyens de répondre impassible attaques y
compris
sur leur frontière dessus de n'y a rien
de surprenant dans le fait que nous
suivons de près le sud de la biélorussie
c'est seulement à
1500 km nous cherchons à nous protéger
nous cherchons des possibilités d'où on
pourrait mener sa défendre notre défense
nous avons un système de défense
antimissile commun avec la russie nous
avons un groupe unifié désarmement nous
avons une armée commune nous avons des
centres de formation des spécialistes et
nous avons la doctrine militaire de
notre union des deux états nous avons
nous n'avons jamais caché ces documents
à personne tout le monde est au courant
de ce que nous avons donc ces exercices
sont dus à l'alliance actuelle nos
exercices sont menées d'une manière
absolument transparents non les
maintenant sur notre territoire nous ne
cachons rien à personne nous sommes
suivis de près par une armée d'attaché
de presse
la politique extérieure
comprend nous avons également parlé de
l'intégration de notre union des deux
états quatre mois ont passé après la
signature du décret de l'union des deux
états où on voit les directions
principales de la mise en oeuvre de
l'accord de la création de l'union des
deux états pour les années 2002 et 2003
mais nous avons une vingtaine de
programmes comment nous avons à réaliser
ce moment à peu près 20% de ce que nous
avons prévu qu'est ce qui a été réalisé
qui ont été les progrès ça a été bien
décrit notamment par le président
maintenant une attention particulière
maintenant
concerne la fiscalité la coopération de
manière la création du marché unifié de
gaz
encore
souffriront beaucoup ceux qui essaient
d'être à l'avant-garde à cette guerre
des sanctions nous avons accordé une
attention particulière à ce sujet parce
que ce banditisme cette tentative de
nous imposer une guerre économique déjà
été déclenchée contre nous ça nous coûte
cher
nous avons certainement appris à lutter
contre ces sections nous avons renforcé
nos positions nos échanges en sont la
preuve mais tout de même nous sommes
obligés de prêter une attention
particulière à la lutte contre cette
pression des sanctions nous avons mis
beaucoup de temps à discuter aujourd'hui
avec le président je vous remercie
monsieur poutine d'avoir donné des
ordres
justement
à la direction
et vous n'avez rien cacher vous l'avez
fait un
maintenant à ma présence je vous en
remercie nous les russes et les
biélorusses nous allons sortir nous
allons résister à cette guerre hybride
et c'est évident pour tout le monde nous
voyons que nous avons une plus forte
coopération dans l'industrie nous voyons
des dizaines de nouvelles marchandises
dans la structure de nos échanges
commerciaux on voit à la diversification
de nos flux de commerce le monde est
grand on ne peut pas à mettre une
serrure sur toutes les portes on peut
pas couper tous les voix de
transportation encore un sujet de
négociation c'est l'économie et nous
sommes contents d'avoir bien coopéré
l'année dernière malgré les pandémies
les virus nous avons réussi à augmenter
notre nos échanges jusqu'à 40 milliards
il faut en tenir compte les exportations
on sait qu'il n'ya pas de frontière
entre la russie et la biélorussie et
donc ça nous apportent des milliards de
dollars c'est vrai que nos deux
économies ont connu une croissance
active dans en termes de tempo des pib
de la production industrielle
et dans d'autres secteurs
du secteur réel de l'économie nous avons
évidemment parlé plus tôt des problèmes
que des succès il se deviennent moins
nombreux mais quand même il existe nous
avons écouté le moi de soutenir les
économies la stabilité financière à
l'augmentation des activités d'affaires
et une plus intense coopération j'ai
informé certainement monsieur le
président comment se prépare en
biélorussie en en référendum
constitutionnel nous allons le réaliser
avec dignité pour les intérêts du peuple
biélorusse là ne contredira aucunement à
nos relations avec le pays fraternel qui
est la russie pour nous l'occident hissé
de
de déstabiliser aux noix ou bien deux
rendre la situation dans notre pays
moins stable en utilisant des personnes
fugitive mais il ne faut pas avoir des
lésions et des illusions que
l'institution pourrait se répéter c'est
important nous pourrons ensemble
surmonter toutes les situations
difficiles nous opposer à tous les défis
et construire notre avenir commun il je
ne veux que personne compte sur
notre défaite nous n'allons jamais
tomber devant les difficultés des
problèmes je vais répéter quelque chose
que je viens de dire que sa mort ne
voulons pas de guerre mais si quelqu'un
a vraiment une forte envie de ça la
réponse sera tout à fait asymétrique
je pense que tout le monde le comprend
dans le monde entier c'est évident et en
défendant la sécurité de nos peuples et
de nos états nous allons agir d'une
manière adéquate
monsieur poutine vient de le souligner
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec lui on
ne cesse de nous séparer non seulement
la russie et la biélorussie mais ose
aussi les tous les pays qui ont
l'intention de s'unifier ce n'est pas le
chemin à prendre et vous n'aurez rien
vous ne réussirez rien le kazakhstan en
est la preuve nos la pression je vous
remercie pour votre attention
[Musique]
vous avez vous le voir création sera loi
de l'andouillette roussillon sera de
près vous avez vu justement c'est ce que
les médias en discuter
oui
messieurs les présidents peut-être et
vous reviendriez au micro parce que
sinon on peut pas avoir le champ s'il
vous plaît donnez s'il vous plaît le
micro aux journalistes
kommersant oui
on nous a dit que vous pouvez pose que
nous pouvons poser une question
ils vont me demander combien de temps je
resterai président vous avez dit
récemment que si l'occident continuent
d'être agressifs ou serai un président
éternel
comment évaluez vous les chances du
peuple bulle heureuse de vous perdre en
tant que président parce que je pense
que ses chances sont minimes à présent
et une question pour le président russe
monsieur poutine comment avez vous
vécu survécu la lente invention de la
russie en ukraine qui vient d'avoir lieu
si vous permettez je veux j'ai je n'ai
absolument pas
attiré mon attention là dessus il ya
tellement de fausses informations peut
pas réagir à tous ma santé ma vie est
plus importante
je fais ce que j'estime nécessaire et
nous continuerons à agir de cette façon
bien sûr nous regardons ce qui se passe
dans le monde mais nous savons très bien
quelles sont nos priorités
les intérêts de la russie du peuple
russe
ce putin on n'est pas entré en ukraine
ils sont tellement triste qui cherchait
des prétextes pour pousser l'ukraine à
des provocations en ce qui concerne ma
présidence
on va discuter avec mon frère avec mon
grand frère et on va prendre la décision
ce que vous avez dit ça me surprend que
commerçante discutent de cette manière
là les chances de ces personnes
de casser la biélorussie par force sont
minimes
c'est très bien dit ils vont devenir
encore plus minime avec le temps ils
n'auront rien et le peuple biélorusse
ils peuvent dire que nous sommes une
dictature qu'on
pressent sur des gens mais ça n'a rien à
voir avec cela à personne ne fais une
pression sur les gens nous réagissions
d'une manière adéquate à ce qu'ils
poussent à effectuer un coup d'état en
biélorussie ils ont poussé les gens à le
faire voilà c'est ça
pour avoir la parité de la même manière
qu'ils ont fait ça en ukraine et au vont
lui faire la même chose et ils n'ont pas
réussi ils ne réussiront jamais ce n'est
pas pour rien que j'ai parlé du
kazakhstan
alors à servas
cher président ma question est pour les
deux dans vos interventions vous avez
évoqué la guerre des sanctions
déclenchée contre nous et contre vous
nous voyons qu'il y a une pression qui
devient de plus en plus forte on voit
qu'il ya eu la fermeture des 36
et ont menacé sanctions
vous avez dit monsieur loukachenko quand
nombreux de d'ordre a été donné
comment voyez-vous les
les réponses aux sanctions possibles
dans le contexte de l'intégration et de
la coopération et dans la lutte contre
les sanctions qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
et qui pourrait nous aider dans ce sens
je sais on doit céder nous-mêmes ça
c'est clair et c'est justement l'objet
de notre discussion d'aujourd'hui
c'était au coeur de notre attention et
monsieur l'occassion qu'on l'a dit c'est
la question et konami c'est notre
coopération économique
comme l'a dit de façon très imagée le
monde est grand on peut pas tous fermés
avec daphné avec dédé des clés avec des
serrures et c'est vrai que c'est ainsi
nous avons parlé sur l'ensemble des pros
des questions qui restent problématiques
ce dont vous avez parlé aussi mais je
vais pas entrer dans les détails mais il
ya toujours des solutions
dans quelle direction devant nous
avancer je l' ai déjà dit je souligne
cette pression par les sanctions
première chose elle est complètement
illégitime c'est une grave infraction
droit international et ceux qui en
parlent actuellement il n'en parle que
quand il parle du droit international
que quand ça les avantage c'est tout
pour le reste ils oublient nous
malheureusement nous sommes dans ce
paradigme depuis de nombreuses années
parce que le le pouvoir comme et comme
il se caractérise il interprète tout en
leur faveur et négligent les intérêts
des autres
mais la voix pour surmonter toutes ces
difficultés c'est de nous renforcer de
l'intérieur et en premier lieu sur le
plan économique on parle de sanction les
sanctions de toute façon elles seront
introduites si un prétexte aujourd'hui
lié aux événements de l'ukraine ou pas
de toute façon ils trouveront un
prétexte parce que leur objectif c'est
de freiner le développement de nos pays
en l'occurrence de la russie et de la
biélorussie
le on trouvera toujours un prétexte pour
imposer telle ou telle sanction
illégitime je le répète et crée une
concurrence déloyale
et tout
tout est dit là depuis huit ans nous a
fait beaucoup en russie c'est ce qu'on
appelle les substitution aux
importations
nous n'avons pas fait tout ce que nous
prévoyons mais on peut dire que dans
l'ensemble à 90 % et même un peu plus
nous avons satisfait aux objectifs que
nous nous étions fixés il reste encore
beaucoup de choses à faire mais ça ça
signifie que c'est un une élévation du
niveau de souveraineté économique et
aujourd'hui il y à beaucoup de pays et
même des alliés des etats-unis qui font
l'objet de sanctions
jean sont fermés ils se taisent ils
supportent ces difficultés mais
ça fait longtemps que je dis ça ne plaît
à personne toutes les avanies que ce
soit des sanctions directes ou
indirectes tôt ou tard ça va finir par
exploser pour nous aujourd'hui ce qui
est important c'est de relever notre
souveraineté économique et être plus
apte à réagir aux
difficultés pour pouvoir
nous développer et assurer le
développement économique c'est la
numérisation c'est l'intelligence un tel
intellectuel c'est la génétique et
cetera et cetera c'est un travail très
complexes difficiles qui se résout pas
en un jour en tout cas il faut continuer
et les processus d'intégration sur
lequel notre à 20 ils sont concentrés
justement là-dessus c'est à dire
améliorer notre compétitivité et sur
cette base
nous allons chercher à élever le niveau
de vie de nos citoyens et je pense que
c'est tout ce qu'on peut dire sur ce
sujet pour
en tout cas dans le cadre d'une
conférence de presse les sas de noé
gociations en tant que résultat
je peux dire que nous avons accordé
beaucoup de temps aux questions
économiques et surtout à la pression des
sanctions le président vient de dire les
sens quoi qu'on fasse
quelles que soient nos tentatives de
faire quelque chose même si nous voyons
nos intérêts nos peuples avant tout ils
trouveront toujours un prétexte pour
continuer à
intensifier cette guerre économique il
ne s'agit plus de sanctions tout simple
c'est une guerre économique contre notre
union c'est ça l'essence en ce qui
concerne des choses concrètes
monsieur poutine n'a pas parlé en détail
mais nous avons et évoqué des questions
détaillées des sujets à présent vous
avez parlé des engrais potassiques
je remercie monsieur poutine d'avoir
donné l'ordre parce que j'ai demandé
jeudi que nous avions besoin d'un port
on nous affirme et en violant les règles
les accords internationaux d accès on
nous affirmait des accès à des ports où
nous avons travaillé ceci n'est pas
possible si un pays n'a pas de sortie
vers la mer personne ne peut fermer
cette voie
par exemple la russie a accès à la mer
elle ne ferme à personne cet axe est la
lituanie la lettonie et le cren 11 ses
accès ils ont fermé cet accès et c'est
une violation le président le président
a donné l'ordre je les demande est de
nous aider
il ne s'agit pas ce n'est pas une
question d'argent nous avons de l'argent
pour le faire mais j'ai demandé le
président de nous donner l'opportunité
de construire notre port est
passé par ce port des millions de tonnes
des frais et c'est justement à ma
présence que cet ordre a été donné de
commencer la construction nous allons
pendant une année une année et demie
je ne suis pas exactement qui est sur un
le volume mais nous allons
envoyer des millions de tonnes
des frais mais si
nos parts aux deux le crès de la
lituanie dont 30 pour cent pour cent du
budget s'était nous à nous nous n'allons
jamais retourné ça a été très bien dit
quelles que soient les situations les
sanctions c'est
quelque chose qui a quelque chose à voir
avec les opportunités et on allait
substitution des
importations
par exemple si
on regarde ces 10% nous allons sortir de
cette situation qui aura qu il arrive
même pour des questions les plus
sensibles pour les bills oui c'est pour
les russes
concernant des sujets et des
technologies les plus modernes et tout
ça nous savons tout faire nous avons
montré
une fois la pandémie a commencé qui a
été la première à produire le vaccin
c'est la russie elle a fourni le vaccin
aux biélorusses et maintenant
on a de ceux déjà on a déjà produit plus
de deux millions de doses de vaccins
russe en biélorussie avec les
technologies russes nous avons réussi à
faire ça nous allons réussir à faire
d'autres choses
merci on peut maintenant partir déjà
peut-être vous allez nous faire revenir
encore